there are actually seven warning signs
of a vitamin d
deficiency now recently i looked how
many videos i have in vitamin d on
youtube and i found out it was 326
videos so i'm sure that you've seen
pretty much all of them but if you
haven't this video is kind of a summary
of the key warning signs
but what you need to realize is that a
warning sign or a symptom
is not the problem it is an indicator
of a problem that is not
the problem and i'm going to let you in
on a little secret
the medical profession
treats
indicators
okay they treat the indicators and the
treatment lasts for about 24 hours
because if you only treat the indicators
you have to keep treating them over and
over and over again
and the same thing happens with your
garden or in farming if you have
excessive weeds or pests or
insects
you know you might think those are the
problem but they're really not
they're an indicator that there's
something going on with your soil
some condition that is not good
or with the plant that is unhealthy
you know there is actually a great test
and i'm going to do a video on this it's
called a bricks test and it's a very
simple inexpensive test that anyone can
do
on their garden plants or fruit to
determine on a certain scale
how healthy or fertile that plant or
fruit is and if that plant or fruit is
above 12
it's immune from insects insects do not
touch it they don't eat it they don't
start to destroy it insects go after
plants that are dying and decaying but
they don't go after
healthy fruits or
plants which is very fascinating in our
body it's the same thing you're as
strong as your weak link if your
system is weakened you're very
susceptible to pathogens viruses
bacteria etc so it's really important to
understand and differentiate between
an indicator
and the real problem today we're going
to talk about the seven indicators of a
vitamin d deficiency which is at the
root cause of many different problems
so let's start with number one
high blood pressure okay that is one
indicator that your vitamin d is low in
fact it's a real common one
there's two things that i find that can
help resolve
hypertension one is vitamin d and number
two is potassium but vitamin d is
intimately involved because it can act
as an ace inhibitor they use ace
inhibitors for
i think it's 48
of all first line treatments for high
blood pressure okay and vitamin d acts
like an ace inhibitor if you're
deficient in vitamin d
you'll get arterial stiffness in fact
there's a huge correlation between
people having low vitamin d and having
hypertension in fact i'd be really
curious if anyone who had high blood
pressure didn't have a vitamin d
deficiency okay number two low back pain
this is a really good
indicator that you're low in vitamin d
especially if you get like achiness in
your lower back in the muscles
and if you have low back achiness at
night when you're trying to sleep
classic vitamin d deficiency
in fact vitamin d is one of the most
powerful anti-inflammatories natural
anti-inflammatories because it acts
like a steroid it acts like
prednisone but without the side effects
so you could virtually have inflammation
anywhere in your body not just the lower
back all right number three
blood sugars now this is interesting
when you're low in vitamin d
you're way more susceptible to getting
insulin resistance and you're way more
likely for that insulin resistance to
turn into a pre-diabetes and you're more
likely for the pre-diabetes to turn into
diabetes why because vitamin d has a
very important purpose
of maintaining your beta cells in your
pancreas the cells that
control
insulin
all right number four
virus susceptibility there's not one
aspect of your immune system that does
not have receptors for vitamin d vitamin
d is the most important vitamin for your
immune system so if you're low in
vitamin d you're way more susceptible to
not just getting a viral infection but a
bacterial infection
as well and so vitamin d protects you
against
pathogens and it also
can help to regulate excessive amounts
of inflammation as in the cytokine storm
in your lungs
all right five autoimmune conditions i
don't think there's any autoimmune
disease out there that does not have a
severe low vitamin d situation when
you're low in vitamin d you're highly
susceptible to having immune problems
as well as developing an autoimmune
condition and
vitamin d is one of the best natural
treatments for autoimmune why
because it's a powerful
anti-inflammatory and think about what
autoimmune conditions are autoimmune
conditions are a situation where your
body is attacking itself it's an immune
system that has gone rogue and you
always have inflammation in fact it's
the inflammation that is causing
most of the symptoms with autoimmune
conditions so if you were to take
higher amounts of vitamin d you know
like maybe 30
40 50 ius of vitamin d every day you'd
probably notice remarkable improvement
in your autoimmune condition
all right number six
daytime sleepiness you can call this
fatigue
you can call this just being tired
huge connection with low vitamin d now i
don't know if that's because vitamin d
is intimately involved with your sleep
especially behind sleep apnea and you
just feel tired vitamin d helps the
cells that control the circadian waves
and without enough vitamin d
it can really throw off not just your
circadian waves but just make you feel
lethargic kind of tired all day and
especially if you like have a really
hard time getting up in the morning
we know you need vitamin d and it's
interesting about vitamin d because
sunlight actually helps increase vitamin
d so i wonder if there's a connection
with that all right number seven
depression is a really good indicator
that you need vitamin d
now why because vitamin d is needed to
convert
tryptophan which is an amino acid into
serotonin okay
serotonin is a hormone that really helps
your mood and if you're deficient you
can be very depressed and you need as a
requirement tryptophan
for the creation of serotonin and so
vitamin d is needed for this conversion
and this is another point i'll bring up
for depression
i don't think there is a
case of depression that does not have an
underlying vitamin d deficiency now can
you imagine if someone had
any one of these or all of these okay
the indicators are being treated with a
medication
how much confusion that's going to be
because one medication is going to
create other side effects and you don't
know what's causing what but
unfortunately the system is set up to
manage your
indicators and not treat underlying
causes i want to bring up another point
now you could be having
you know being on the sun getting enough
vitamin d
you could be eating foods with some
vitamin d you could be taking the
vitamin d supplement and still have
problems for various reasons which i'm
going to cover right now
number one you can have which is
becoming more common a genetic defect is
called polymorphism if you had some
genetic testing
and you had a vitamin d receptor
mutation
that could be the reason why
taking normal amounts of vitamin d is
not not going to work the other thing is
that the rdas for vitamin d are i think
if i'm not mistaken like 600 ius which
is a joke because that research has been
done primarily on bone formation
but not all the other things that it can
do
so if you're taking 600 ius thinking
you're getting enough
on top of
absorption problems if you have gut
inflammatory conditions or past damage
from an antibiotic
you're not going to absorb vitamin d2
well if you don't have enough
liver function because your liver is
fatty you're not going to be able to
produce the bile
to be able to absorb vitamin d not to
mention
the activation of vitamin d because in
our bodies we have inactive vitamin d
and we have active vitamin d you need
the liver and kidney to deactivate that
also if you're low in zinc or magnesium
you're not going to absorb vitamin d too
well
also if you're getting older you need
more vitamin d to create the effect or
if your skin is darker you're going to
have more melanin that's going to block
vitamin d so if you're on the sun it
takes a lot more sun to create more
vitamin d or if you are overweight okay
or
insulin resistance which is also
uh the cause of being overweight that
can block your ability to absorb vitamin
d so you can see there are so many
other reasons why people
might be deficient now make sure if
you're taking vitamin d you take as a
maintenance dosage 10 000 i use okay if
you think that's a lot of vitamin d you
should watch my video down below
always take vitamin k2 with vitamin d so
vitamin d helps absorb calcium by 20
times more so here we have all this
calcium in the blood right
so that's actually performed with
vitamin d but we also need vitamin k2 to
help take that calcium in the blood and
deliver the other half into the bones if
we don't have enough k2
sometimes that calcium can deposit in
the arteries as well as in your joints
and other tissues
so the ratios
of
vitamin d3 to k2 would be like 10 000
iu's of d3
to 100 micrograms
of k2
there's different versions the one that
i recommend is the natural form which is
m7 all right now that you have the
basics on vitamin d
some people are concerned about toxicity
i think you should watch that video next
i put it up right here check it out